oh thank you yes of course I was trying
to be quiet I walked in we were just
talking about the documentary that Hulu
did on the Dana Carvey show have you
seen it I haven't seen it here it's
great so good that's so cool no you a
fan I never yeah I remember I was kinda
I I was always a fan of his on SNL and I
remember I don't I'm probably one of the
reasons why the show didn't go because I
didn't watch enough but I always heard
it was hilarious they were they were
showing like how poorly it was matched
up with home improvement because that
was like home improvement was like the
nicest show yeah on TV and it was like
the quintessential sitcom and they
actually showed in the documentary
because what they did for Dana Carvey
show was as a joke mmm they had a real
sponsor sponsored every week so it would
be the Taco Bell Dana Carvey show the
mountain dew Dana Carvey show just as
like a goof and they showed this
commercial and they said on Tuesday a
very special home-improvement and they
were going what's it like when a parent
has to face losing a child and Thomas is
like I don't want to die dad Tim Tim
Allen's like we're gonna get through
this in this big hug and then it goes on
an all-new home improvement followed by
Mountain Dew Dana Carvey show nothing
took you down faster than those very
special episode Dudley and ro in the tub
with mr. Carlson from W didn't love that
did you just cynically laugh your way
through every every very special episode
yeah standing ovations yeah that moved
me I'd cry at laugh goes wonderful I
never did a very special Freaks and
Geeks maybe if it had gone on like a few
seasons you'd get to a place where
you're like oh yeah we need to do a very
special way we had a pot-smoking episode
that I think the network tried to sell
it was ironic it was the last episode
before we got cancelled so maybe maybe
it did take us down kind of colonna's
that's good what Dad yeah what is it
well what I'm well well thank you Jim if
you can smell it from across the room
too much oh thank you it's a pen
Halligan's called a hell Fetty it's very
thank you very interesting smell thank
you sir well always looks very very well
quaffed and well dressed and very neat
too presentable and
and he smells rich is it is it a Paul
Feig suit
well Novak I'm where you know it's not
but thank you you remember yes the jig
crew lines sold out oh is it yes it did
so okay well yeah but there's still
accessories if you want available online
I don't know a the thing is that
everybody that brought me in to do it is
gone so so basically oh no there's a
mess firing firing because of me
that's what I do yeah you know it's fun
my Twitter feed is very exciting because
you're the fans of your shirt clearly
excited them let me say to your face I
love the fans of the salmon gym show in
the gym and Sam's oh and they should
just you're fun guest oh like the
Ghostbusters thing they're holding on
but you're a fun guest I don't I'm gonna
like you you're an open guy you're fun
it makes you feel any better I get that
reaction to being on this show we're
unique fraternity yeah yeah all the
people that are [ __ ] on you on
Twitter Jim and I have probably muted
because they [ __ ] on us when you're not
around if there been anything better
than than the mute button yeah because
they don't know no and then you realize
you know what's amazing I had this
experience over the weekend when like
you realize that somebody that used to
kind of get under your skin
on Twitter or something like you're like
you finally just muted them and then
weeks go by and you're like oh my god I
forgot that they ever existed yeah
exactly they were disappeared my life is
so much nicer right oh I wish I knew
about that mute button years ago and you
also realize how like when it doesn't
matter when people are just bad-mouthing
you but when it's just because hey we
think you suck we don't like you like it
doesn't like yeah let them I mean they
doesn't mean anything right it's fine
people have always had opinions just
because it's on the internet doesn't
make it any more or less valid no it's
just the fact that it's in your phone
with equal weight with everybody else
that comes in your phone
yeah thanks from your wife a tweet some
random dude giving you the business
today oh yeah
Britt's here in there it's all good
natured fun right exactly
no like favorite thing is that I
wouldn't write back when ghostbusters
are coming out entertain no sorry The
Hollywood Reporter said hey would you
write a satirical column for us about
why men aren't funny
you know that's clearly just you know a
joke and it said sure so I wrote this
thing send that to me like it's serious
yeah which kind of makes me laugh
actually I go like wow if you really
think that I'm saying that men are not
funny right god bless you you would like
to think of yourself as a man who is
funny yeah and you're working with the
Joel McHale show with Joel McHale yeah
episodes every Sunday exclusively on
Netflix what is this this is you know
Joe's old show called the soup yes where
he makes fun of clips I wouldn't that
was my favorite show in all the world my
wife and I that's the only thing I've
ever taped to watch religiously every
week and then he got cancelled and I
said with God is my witness I'm gonna
get Joel McHale another clip show where
he can be hilarious no he is and thanks
the Lionsgate TV came in and helped us
out but it was really it was it's all
because of dogs dogs are the reason why
this is back I was out walking my dog in
my neighborhood with my wife and we ran
into KP Anderson who was the exact
producer of the soup and I've been on
the show a few times and then it said
like why how could we get the show back
I want and I tried going through my
agents and ever he says well he owns the
rights to that one I said how do we just
get Joel back on a clip show it doesn't
it's not the soup but and he said well
interestingly I was just talking to Joel
the other day and he's kind of
interested in possibly doing doing
something like this again and so with
the open so we met and gotten together
and then suddenly we sold this to
Netflix that's great oh that's where
okay everywhere now and it's over the
weekend and it's I like that you guys
added instead of having the sort of
audience that you'd like you was the
cameraman that would generally like my
stuff that Joe would do now there's like
a small audience Nancy in the first
episode like they're kind of laughing
and responding to the stuff that joel
saying but I think it's I think it's an
interesting premise for Netflix
that I think Netflix the one spot that
they're struggling in is trying to
figure out how something topical works
on
like I think they were kind of trying to
figure that out with Chelsea
no no Chelsea we're the we're only the
second time they've done like a weekly
Rice and now they just picked up
Michelle wolf for a show and stuff so
they're definitely getting into it
I think they they really should you know
because it's just such a great platform
the only the only thing we have is we
have to wait about 36 hours between when
we tape it when we can put it up so they
can run there but I think I think the
clip show is the way to go because it is
the type of thing that you would watch
online anyway but it's also like if you
don't watch the first day it's out you
can go back like the clips are still
funny right yeah exactly but you know
but also there was talk at beginning of
like well do all 13 old Benjamin's like
no we can't do that because they also
wanted to be clips of the week right
feels topical yeah yeah exactly so they
I mean Netflix has been the greatest
partner on this because just they get it
in there they're fans of joel's and you
know and they you know in Joe so great
because he wants it to be low tech you
know we didn't want to make it look
fancy at all so you know it's just a
green screen again and even this you
know the audience is kind of a folding
chairs we have a bit of a set but it's
just that GarageBand feel to it which I
didn't I was really I didn't want to
lose that either just I'd like the
purity of that show with the small
audience yeah people individual laughs
and that's what we got so how many
people do you have to hire to look for
clips we have a pretty sizable staff I
would imagine yeah I mean the good thing
is the lot of the people who worked on
the soup are back working behind the
scenes with us and then what's the
process for like clip submission and
what makes it like how do you we just
have this great staff that just goes
through clips all day long and now we've
added this big international component
to it of international clips and that's
actually so many funny we have the on
this current one that's out right now
there's a hilarious runner from these
the Korean soap operas of how they love
people getting hit by cars apparently on
the show I mean everybody's gonna hit my
car that's hilarious but they go through
and and and we have these meetings every
day called clip meetings and people just
present all these clips and we watch and
crack up and go like okay that one maybe
that one maybe that one and then you
know the Brad Boyd our head writers get
in there and they just kind of do it all
and then we have a team of amazing
writers who then you know write these
wraps for wrap arounds for each each
clip and it just you know just over the
course of the week it just kind of comes
together and then joel is you know kind
of gives his final say whatever happened
to John Henson who was who was doing
that I was Kinnear and then John Henson
and then Joel and I thought John to be
away you know much about him problems he
just a comic now yeah because he was
always super funny to watch those years
- so is this the type of thing where you
can kind of set it and forget it like
you can set the whole thing up and then
go and be like okay I put the right guys
in charge I mean yeah hands on do you
have to be well III that show would run
itself absolutely I'm just such a fan
and it's so much fun then I just like oh
I love being there it's so much fun and
like almost like words kind of might cut
into my other work just you know like
yeah okay guy we don't need you here but
it's just it's it's the most fun place
to be how many weeks did they pick you
up for 13 is the first order but I'm
hoping we can push that much longer
because this is the kind of show that
just needs to kind of come on every week
for you know all year it's gotta be a
nice relief for Joel too cuz he was
doing like I mean he was doing you know
community does the [ __ ] White House
Correspondents these are like you know
there's a lot no this is just much more
of a fun laid-back he's good and he's
really good you know he's out doing
stand-up you know every weekend and
stuff like that so it really it's it's
it's good and it you know doesn't
require you know mountains of his time
you can put as much time or as little as
he wants into it do you like doing
something weekly like this I mean you've
done stuff before but you like the
topical feel of it I do board I love it
I you know it's just like having this
great toy train up and running that you
can play with all the time it was just I
mean honestly this was completely
selfish it's just cuz I missed that show
so much I just wanted it back on the air
are you gonna like do it
Newsies stuff at all are you
specifically trying to avoid yeah the
only only news politics we will ever do
would be making fun of the coverage of
something right you know we're not gonna
get in dive in any kind of politics
whatsoever but even difficult to do that
though because it's like well of course
they're gonna make fun of Fox News yeah
well of course they're gonna make fun of
CNN we know exactly where they stand now
home I'm just trying to tell Joe that
right yeah we just want to find like a
funny anchor a weird thing you know
somebody works on the air whatever it's
like right so it'll it'll take a lot for
that you know for us to do something
like that but if we
do it'll be really funny yeah that's the
whole yeah it's kind of hard cause no
matter where you are now people think
you're taking a stance even if you're
just making five scene guys I know
making fun of Trump people get mad or
people pay for the hell you like you
can't even make fun of people without
thinking you're lining up taking sides
of the gun in your hand yeah and it's
just nice to take a break from them so
many people are doing it so well that
was just like let's just have a show
where you just laugh yeah I don't get
mired in all that yeah I didn't know
what the show was when they were first
talking about it I just didn't look into
it much and then when it popped up on
Netflix I was like it let me just see
what it is when I see it and I was so
relieved to realize it was like that for
Matt and he started playing clips from
The Bachelor and stuff and I guess this
is I hope he could just watch it and
have a good time and it's easy I
couldn't wait till he started streaming
because everybody was kind of
conjecturing is what kind of talk show
this and that does it's one guys it's
just you're gonna know exactly what it
is when it comes back right Nick is in
like the teasers for it it almost looked
like it might be like a John Oliver type
show it was like Joel McHale and it was
showing him with all the stuff going on
and Joel McHale is gonna make sense of
it but then it comes on and it's it's
the clip show format and you're like
these making up about chiller I'm
pitching a show now it's kind of similar
yeah oh really yeah what is it just me
going places and really telling it like
it is ranting into the camera I like it
Wow I watched an hour and a half a week
[Laughter]
you don't need to hire writers because
just off the top of your head I'm like
you give me a subject you know I'll just
rant for an hour
bun Jim let's talk to this show funny
how the word rant has just become so
little oh I know used to be kind of
imply something fun would happen in the
90s was they always ranting
Denis Leary was a good rant er like you
get guys that were totally
remember Leno was the king of that when
he'd gone on Letterman
oh okay and he go like much my beef Dave
what's my beef and he would like be
hilarious cuz he would just rant you
know the fun days of ranting right rant
or riff or whatever it is then it became
someone a rant became you were gonna be
self-righteous Alex Jones became the
king of the ranch right yeah I think
he's good at it you know yes I just
think a Rambo became something else like
yeah angry connotation yeah
Rann should just be kind of like just
complaining about something to happen to
you I feel like yeah do you do you find
that people are trying to pitch you a
lot since you you know become kind of
known as this guy who creates um what I
get more than anything is people just
email me like scripts and it's like dude
don't email me a script because that
puts me in legal trouble so we have to
like bracket it right not read them no I
don't think I get will not read it I
don't open I send it to my agent to my
assistant who sends it back to them if
they're close enough that they know what
your email address is wouldn't they know
the rules of how this thing no I don't
know who these people are at all they
just figure out you're somehow my my
company's email is out on the internet
somewhere so it all comes into my phone
and it's always it's not that hard to
find you know people could find anything
these days yeah exactly
we had my number is our friend sandy
Kane was had a cameo in the Florida
project and but she's kind of a disaster
of a person but she said fine like we
like she's a delight which is not a
movie star by any stretch of the
imagination
so she heard that Willem Dafoe was gonna
be around and she was like we should do
the show together I'm like okay I mean
we don't have Willem Dafoe booked as
probably he's doing other shows or
whatever so I start getting emails with
that she is sending out and it's to my
email and then Willem Dafoe gmail.com
and I'm like oh I guess she just knows
Willem Dafoe from the set maybe they
were emailing and she came on and she
was like oh yeah no I just took a stab I
just put Willem Dafoe it probably did
actually it's like writing Santa North
Pole and putting it in place like I'm
sure it'll go to the right person I got
a few famous people that I go what your
email address and it is their name at
you know somewhere you're like oh what
server it is isn't it dot me is it a
gmail what is it you threw me up a drag
yeah when they send weird stuff like
that sick you don't they think you're
being like I won't read jokes admit I
don't want to no no no totally I don't
because again then all the said if you
do something in eight years that reminds
them of one paragraph for that even
though totally it's like [ __ ] that I
might get myself an upfront prob what it
what is it what is the people have to
send it to an agent a lot of times yes
yeah leo and they
a release form and yeah these things ya
know because I that's my nightmare is
like even like the subject line is like
shut the script I'm writing right now
you know
vampires and on Mars like yeah I'm
writing the vampires I used Venus need
to hold this hot there Mars the red is
the red planet blind it was too much too
obvious a time damn it that's what we
have to work together yeah yeah you have
to be careful I don't want jokes images
for that reason and then people think
that you turkeys remembers like no have
you been accused of stealing stuff me no
no I I mean not since high school when I
stole all of Steve Martin's act and
pretended it was mine right yeah but no
no I'm fortunately yeah exactly we gonna
stand up yeah
oh no no well I was I I was the first
person to my school to discover Steve
Martin and so memorize the first album
and then would just recite it to all my
friends like oh my god you're the
funniest guy in the world then he became
more popular and a valuable lesson of
the young age not to do that I used to
watch out watch Carson Layton tape like
Rodney and Robert Shaw and all those
guys cassette yeah yeah yeah just a
piece-of-shit audio cassette of Rodney
[ __ ] uh oh yeah the same dirty lines
from movie certain like from used cars
certain lines it just resonated mm-hmm
and you memorized them oh you just want
some back to the power of profanity Oh
God I used to I used to tape on my
cassette player Fernwood tonight and
always play that back oh you know what I
did not know that who's in that was it
Martin Martin mall yeah and uh Fred
Willard okay that's the funny [ __ ] they
don't I think for some reason there's
some music right so though you can't
rerelease that that was the funniest
show and it was night it was a nightly
you know like fake talk show super funny
it was from the same people you remember
a show called Mary Hartman Mary are sure
yeah it was the same people that did
that I don't know what that was about
that was a fake soap opera and again it
was nightly this you know it's crazy
thing now we're we're so we're so lazy
now we can't pull off stuff they own
weekly barely right now you know every
night five nights a week they had stuff
how long was Mary Hartman Mary Hartman
on it was a huge
show that was probably on for two three
four years okay the actual soap opera or
do they show you behind the scenes of
the Soul prom no actual soap opera and
they played it all dead serious but it
was completely crazy she looked like the
Wendy's girls you know it was Louise
Lasser who was Woody Allen's first wife
I think and she was Mary Hartman it was
just super weird it's amazing that
people like you know like Adult Swim and
stuff like that like people think that
that is so like sort of weird and
counterculture now but the stuff like
this was going on in the 70s ohto it's a
weird thing you know I'm 55 now and it's
like as you get older you don't start to
go you know when you're younger like you
think you discover everything and it is
that thing my dad always said me wow you
kids think you discovered you know all
this stuff and it's like oh god now yeah
that's right you know but people you
know younger people don't remember I
don't think a lot people remember who
Johnny Johnny kart Carson Carson is they
don't I can't even say it that's I
believe if I'm if I'm with a girl and
she doesn't know who Johnny Carson was I
want to [ __ ] her you mean there was some
original stuff in the 70s and people
forget like there was a lot of creative
[ __ ] back then in the 80s maybe a lot of
it was a little hammy but ya know see
I'm writing a movie right now that
actually takes place in the 20s and
going back and researching that like
they [ __ ] crazy wild back then so
you're like alright it's a comedy I'm of
course zooming yes or no do you start
with when you do a film do you will you
your process be definitely just start
and go I'm gonna see where it winds up
or do you want to know the ending I've
stranded myself sometimes when I don't
know the ending is just the middle
sometimes but that's the fun part
because you go okay I got to get to here
so I can keep surprising myself and go
let me take this left turn I don't know
know how to get out of and then the fun
is like figuring it out anytime I've
ever tried to write anything I know the
beginning and the end and as soon as I
start writing the middle I just get
impatient and just want to rush right to
the end it's four pages long or
something I cannot flush anything out
because I know what the ending is like
alright let's just get there let's just
get there okay are we done it's like ya
know you
get four and a half but that's my second
acts are they're hard but that's why if
you have great characters then that they
can let you go start tangents